we all have to recognize the the
strengths and limitations of government
action I think if truth be told my my
inclination is to recognize that that at
least in the u.s. most really good
things start at the local level and work
their way up to the state level in the
federal government because the federal
government moves more slowly than local
level in your father away from people in
their real needs and so I think one of
the things that government needs to do
is listen well but here's what I think
we can do at the federal level more
effectively we can speak to the science
because it's complicated and we do a lot
of research and we do a lot of
translation of the science into what it
means for people so that the decisions
can be made on the basis of real science
and on the basis of a real technical
understanding and we can evaluate those
impacts and put choices out now what you
really want to do at the national level
is send long-term signals and those
signals go to people in markets because
the best thing EPA and other regulatory
agencies need to do is set standards
based on what we think the science tells
us the law tells us and what's
achievable but those need to be
long-term signals because we don't
deliver the solutions we really don't
the market delivers the solution that's
why on things like climate change we're
looking at regulating the power sector
to reduce carbon pollution I am setting
standards out to 2030 because the
solutions are here what you need to do
is give them the time to take hold in
the marketplace and then what happens is
the solutions of today start taking off
but what's most important is the
solutions of tomorrow start getting
driven into the market they take time
it's like being in a race in the federal
government you know says what direction
to run and then this and they shoot the
starting gun but the ones in the race
become the businesses the entrepreneurs
the people who are driving new
technologies that's how it has worked
for in EPA's career for 44 years at EPA
is we've listened to the science and the
law and we have we have let solutions
take off in the marketplace which is
where the the cheapest most effective
always win that's why EPA can move
environmental standards forward so
effectively and grow jobs at the same
time and it's extremely important that I
think everybody think about where
they're how they position themselves at
least in this democracy to be able to
turn it into economic viability and
economic opportunities and nothing lends
itself right now more readily than that
the challenge of climate change